now listen carefully this is a wonderful
story about christmas
listen it was the night before christmas
when all through the house not a
creature was stirring
not even a mouse the stockings were hung
by the chimney with care
in hopes that saint nicholas would soon
be there the children were nestled
all snug in their beds while visions of
sugar plums danced in their heads
and mama and her kerchief and i in my
cap had just settled our brains for a
long winter's nap
when out on the lawn there arose such a
clatter
i sprang from the bed to see what was
the matter
away to the window i flew like a flash
tore open the shutters and threw up the
sash
the moon on the breast of the new fallen
snow gave a luster of mid-day
to objects below when what to my
wondering eyes should appear
but a miniature sleigh and eight
tiny reindeer with a little old driver
so lively and quick
i knew in a moment it must be saint nick
more rapid than eagles his courses they
came
and he whistled and shouted and called
them by name
now dasher now dancer now prancer and
vixen
on comet on cupid on donner and blitzen
to the top of the porch to the top of
the wall
now dash away dash away dash away all
go up to the housetop the coursers they
flew
with a sleigh full of toys and saint
nicholas two
and then in a twinkling i heard on the
roof
the prancing and pawing of each
tiny little hoof as i drew in my head
and was turning around
down the chimney saint nicholas came
with a bound
he was dressed all in fur from his head
to his foot
and his clothes were all covered with
ashes and
soot a bundle of toys he had flung on
his back
and he looked like a peddler just
opening his pack
his eyes how they twinkled
his dimples how merry his cheeks were
like roses
his nose like a cherry his droll
little mouth was drawn up like a bow and
the beard on his chin was as
white as the snow he had a broad face
and a little round belly
that shook when he laughed like a bowl
full of jelly
he was chubby and plump
a right jolly old elf and i laughed when
i saw him
in spite of myself a wink of his
eye and a twist of his head
soon gave me to know i had nothing to
dread
he spoke not a word but went straight to
his work
and filled all the stockings then turned
with a jerk and laying his finger aside
of his nose
and giving a nod up the chimney he rose
he sprang to his sleigh to his team gave
a whistle
and away they all flew like the down of
a thistle
but i heard him exclaim air he drove out
of sight
happy christmas to all and to all
a good night